[Musik]
deutschland hat sehr viel zu diskutieren
die eu empfiehlt ab montag das ende der
massen pflicht im flugzeug während karl
lauterbach das scheitern der allgemeine
impfpflicht als enttäuschende erfahrung
bezeichnet die derzeitige inflation ist
so hoch wie seit 40 jahren nicht mehr
meine gäste heute abend
cdu-bundestagsabgeordneter philipp am
tor er sagt wir brauchen einen echten
schutzschirm gegen die inflation statt
ampel klein kleid professor dr frank
ulrich montgomery
vorsitzender das feld ärzte bundes der
sich fragt wie gut sind wir auf den co-
herbst eigentlich vorbereitet dr günther
frank ist allgemeinarzt und autor wird
heute abend über die nebenwirkungen
durch die krone kämpfen aufklären
journalist georg air france fordert die
fahrrad steuer und kennzeichen pflicht
ich bin sehr gespannt was es damit auf
sich hat und mein name ist lena schick
ich freue mich ihre gastgeberin sein zu
dürfen mein team heute abend die masten
pflicht bei flugreisen endet europaweit
eigentlich ist es eine großartige
neuigkeit besonders für menschen wie
mich die nicht so gerne maske tragen ab
montag kann wenn es nach der eu geht auf
das maske tragen verzichtet werden im
flugzeug aber deutschland geht
selbstverständlich mal wieder erneut den
sonderweg und sieht weiter in der maske
tragen flugzeugen vor danach richte sich
auch die lufthansa erklärte eine
sprecherin der tagesschau die lufthansa
will also warten bis dies in deutsches
recht umgesetzt wird ich frage mich ja
schon seit längerem hat die politik die
massen pflicht im flugzeug und im
öffentlichen personennahverkehr einfach
vergessen der deutsche kroner sonderweg
muss endlich enden mit dem thema möchte
ich die runde eröffnen und direkt die
frage an herrn professor montgomery
geben teilen sie denn meine einschätzung
mein empfinden oder verstehen sie dass
deutschland die masken pflicht immer
noch hat in flugzeugen in der bahn nein
ich teile ihre auf was überhaupt nicht
ich finde sie unsolidarisch schild hier
unhöflich weil ich finde seine art
gerechtigkeit dass ich dann wenn jemand
neben mir sitzt sie nicht produzieren ja
ich hätte auch kein problem hier am haus
gilt ja eine masken pflicht also wir
können die auch bei der sendung hat wenn
sie wollen
natürlich ich habe auch noch zwei den
reserve noch weil ich finde die masken
pflicht ist ein ausdruck von höflichkeit
von q2 sie gegenüber man nachbarn und
sie ist das nach wie vor sinnvollste und
beste mittel um infektionen zu
verhindern sagen wie viele leute sich
nicht impfen lassen wollen ihr habt das
sage ich nicht nur das haben ihnen auch
alle leute nicht alle naja lassen sich
meine moral haben ja in deutschland
inzwischen die einander ist für uns den
meinungen von einigen wenigen reinheit
das sind nicht wenige auch international
wieder sprechen hier auch leute sagen
sie doch mal wie ich es haben sich
angesteckt oder infizieren sich in
öffentlichen nahverkehr und in
flugzeugen versagen sondern mit zahlen
auf dem tisch da gibt's nämlich
untersuchungen die vertragen sie in
deutschland aber sie wissen dass bei
einer insgesamt etwa 5 des sechstägigen
inkubationszeit sie überhaupt nie
nachweisen kann und können ob die
infektion und direkt in ein und wird das
kürzen können doch das training schaffe
dann eben diese maske wird auch langsam
zum symbol der deutschen angst und als
ich bin sehr starken austausch mit der
soul vorstand herrn scheuch der
professor köhler und da kann man
wunderbar diskutieren ob wir über 10%
schutz sprechen 20 prozent aber die
frage ist doch was wurde man schützen
ich meine wer zweifel ja auch nicht
anders ein helm vor kopfverletzungen
schutz tragen wir helme also die frage
wie es denn die
oder will ich einfach erstmal wissen wir
überhaupt die zahlen sind und die
bundesregierung verweigert sich der
evolution wie sinnvoll die sachen sind
und was mir völlig fehlt völlig fehl von
anfang an ist die die ermittlung der
nebenwirkungen meist von massen haben
medizin hat immer auch nebenwirkungen
wenn ich mir die schule anschauen wenn
ich mir die infektion im detail bedeutet
war entwickeln unter diesen rotz faden
die sie da tragen wenn ich mir die
ganzen nebenwirkungen anschauen würde
glaube ich nicht dass wir zu einer
sinnvollen masken pflicht zurückkehren
werden und ich finde das wort
solidarität indem zusammen
überstrapaziert muss ich wirklich sagen
man muss natürlich sagen zu dem ganzen
thema luftverkehr haben wir eine
europäische überlagerung auch unpassend
heute haben übrigens die europäischen
zuständigen einrichtungen entschieden
dass sie sagen die pflicht zum tragen
einer maske den flugzeugen sollte
abgeschafft werden finde ich übrigens
auch nur sinnvoll dass man es europaweit
einheitlich regelt weil das ergibt ja
keinen sinn dass wagen soll durch
endlich mal es ist jetzt heute erst die
entscheidung gekommen dass man sozusagen
empfiehlt auf eu-ebene dass die masken
pflicht feld ersetzt wird durch eine
empfehlung das finde ich auch total okay
herr montgomery weiter seine maske
tragen ich würde den flieger
wahrscheinlich auch machen aber am ende
finde ich schon richtig dass man jetzt
im prinzip beim öffentlichen nahverkehr
und beim flieger gleicht sie zudem habe
ist er jetzt auch entschieden kann auf
keinen fall sagen die irdische
besonderheit der deutsche untertan macht
alles gern mit seit einiger zeit braucht
man nicht mehr im supermarkt lassen sie
mich ausreden der super für noch gar
nicht in der lage waren sich
also sie haben es ist sowohl die pflicht
viel bin ich nur ein supermarkt gegangen
und der gute deutsche trug weiterhin die
maske und es hat sich in kein ich bin
sehr viel im ausland unterwegs es gibt
eine usa starten die besucher der trick
kein einziger einer maske in florida wo
ich ein zweites sause habe da lachen die
leute alle war eine ganz schöne
infektionszahlen ich habe mal
wiedergewählt den anderen
freundlich zu sein da kommt einfach
nicht was auch immer die leute in
amerika amerika machen was sie tun ihr
habt brauchen keine ratschläge aber es
ist natürlich so dass wir ein volk sind
das gern auf waren draufpasst ich habe
nirgendwo erlebt dass sogar zerstört
marktkauf
tisch sein jemand ich denke so komplett
allein im zug das ist ja auch mal haben
wir schon wieder so weit also wir sehen
unter diese mentalität die so klassisch
deutsch ist die geht mir auf den senkel
da haben wir doch recht und wir haben
ein anderes verständnis wir haben einen
anderen als sie vor allem mit verbrochen
und wir haben viel gesehen den leuten
die haben sich rechtfertigen müssen
jetzt haben wir vor
welche
und darf ich mal ungestört leben von
carina und das problem rede von einer
das problem was wir haben ist dass wir
eine gesamtgewinner krise nicht die
experten die im fach sind gefragt haben
sondern sie immer die gleichen die sich
so als universal experten geben wenn man
sie mit den rosen und
werde ich wohl meinen ja dann muss man
auch nachrüsten
wenn man dies zum beispiel köhler schaue
ich mal die zuhört die machen
forschungen an kunst köpfen und so
weiter wir haben ganz klar gesagt das
wird übertragen über ihre sohle sie
stehen im raum in need in engen räumen
fahrstuhl zum beispiel darf man aber
wieder die tür nicht auf wegen
vollschutz gründen aber die wirksamste
maßnahme ist tatsächlich eine lüftung
eine lüftungsanlage die haben vorschläge
gemacht im bundestag vorgelegt keine
resonanz passiert nichts die maske hat
einfach die nebenwirkung die sind nicht
da kümmert sich keiner drum es werden
keine messungen gemacht wie sie die
sauerstoffknappheit aus bei kindern ich
habe viele kinder gesehen die haben
konzentrationsprobleme kopfschmerzen
also hier kommen von ammers geht ja ich
hatte
irgendwie
geben jedoch zu herr scheuch hat am
anfang weil seine forschungen sich
intensiv für masken ausgesprochen da
scheue ich war nie ein gegner der maske
also wir wollen die leute richtig
zitieren zweitens haben wir haben recht
sie haben sie mir nicht recht lüftung
wäre besser aber da wo keine lüftung ist
ja warum wir zu wenig gemacht ja das ist
eine gute frage da bin ich bei ihnen
aber das hat nichts mit der maske
solange wir keine vernünftigen lüfter
haben solange wir in den schulen
versäumen dort anständige luft immer
noch mit maske die ganze zeit versteckt
sein das habe ich ihm gesagt was ich da
für die
kinder da hat
frankreich das kann man durchaus bei
kindern auch anders sehen aber in
öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln da wo wir
auch untereinander uns anstecken können
wir wollen als ärzte nach wie vor
möglichst jede infektion verhindern
müssen dass auch immer bleiben nein das
ist klar gesagt wir haben momentan
wunderbare umgebungsbedingungen wie die
der sommer kommt wir haben viel weniger
infektionen wir können ja heute mit
einer infektionsrate von über 500 sehr
viel besser leben als wir vor zwei
jahren mit 150 es kommt doch garnicht
audi dessen sohn einfach mal sagen es
ist eine frage von höflichkeit dass ich
versuche meine umgebung zu schützen wenn
ich selber infiziert sind oder warum
meldet jetzt also man kommen wenn er
behauptet das macht kannst du nicht sag
jetzt mal warum das ist es ist sie immer
persönlich sie gehen nicht auf andere
argumente ein so finde ich jetzt nein
sie haben diejenigen die keine maske
tragen die vielleicht ein grund haben
als sie wird sache mit corona begann
haben diese herren hier am trikot und
merkel die mutti und so haben gesagt die
am die masken sind viren schleudern wie
gesagt
lieferbar waren hieß es die bringen ja
so was das heißt dieses ganze spiel was
dadurch gezogen wurde deswegen ist sind
viele auch zu unsicher muss ich ihnen
sage wenig person sie sind persönlich
sagen wir sind aber solidarisch das ist
wie wir gesagt haben
ich halte das für außerordentlich
überall wo android erschienen die masken
pflicht von menschen wie ich sind uns
solidarisch
trotzdem krank geworden wir können
solche geschichten erzählt haben er hat
zwei jahren kann man nicht einfach
hergehen und sagen wir brauchen die
massen waren die schützen ich will er
nicht mal alle zahlen haben wie viel das
ist in prozent ja und zwar nicht nur
infektionen auf die kommt doch gar nicht
an sondern schweren verläufen der
todesfälle und diese zahlen haben wir
nicht und wir haben keine forschung zu
neben sprechen er weiter von incidents
deswegen finden ihre flyer ja das
argument maske ist solidarität finde ich
ein moralisches argument was ihnen gut
und böse unterscheiden müssen wir
endlich mal weg davon ich weiß jetzt
nicht ob wir wirklich mal noch mal die
zahlen hervor und und sie wissen ganz
genau dass die einzigen maßnahmen die in
der ersten und in der zweiten welle
wirklich geholfen haben waren die
kontakte beschränkung eine der
einfachsten kontakt beschränkungen die
es überhaupt gibt es das tragen von
masken also wer sich heute hinstellt und
behauptet das wirkt alles überhaupt
nicht gibt kann ich ehrlich gesagt nicht
ganz fern zu halten dann hab ich alles
gesagt ich habe gesagt ich
bin ich zuletzt jetzt auch sie jeden
kontakt beschränkt dann haben sie mich
zu behalten
die maske sind dann die effektivste
warum in den infektionen nachher wenn
sie mit den leuten die sich auskennen
sprechen dann dann diskutieren die opti
an wir wollen einen virenschutz hat von
10 20 30 die frage ist die relation wie
groß ist die gefahr ein beispiel mit
einem helm tragen hat das darauf
angespielt und ich möchte wissen ob
diese 20 cent notwendig sind das
medizinische situation haben wo mir eine
maske brauchen im krankenhaus
immunsuppressiven und so weiter ist doch
selbstverständlich aber in der
öffentlichkeit finde ich dass zunehmend
ein symbol einer irrationalität ich will
endlich eine rationale diskussion haben
über über nutzen und schaden und dann
können wir diskutieren ob es sinnvoll
ist aber als einfach sozusagen das
zeichen von solidarität für mich
inakzeptabel nach zwei jahren
es gibt im jama im journal of the
american medical association ausreichend
arbeiten die belegen dass das tragen
einer maske das infektionsrisiko um 85
prozent senkt also ich weiß gar nicht
was mich noch mal lesen und
was ist das denn fantasie nicht
naja das ist die große frage wer hat
über sterblichkeit gemessen ein
statistisches phänomen was die
mortalität ankowitsch angeht an anja
roßkopf 2 sind wir deutlich besser als
schweden wir haben aber wahrscheinlich
in derselben zeit durch die schließung
von krankenhäusern etc viele operationen
nicht gemacht haben viele andere dinge
nicht gemacht sodass wir statistisch
nach den statistiken der wiro mit einer
über sterblichkeit da kommen aber unterm
strich hat das eventuell gar nichts mit
google zu tun
simuliert wurden die eine operation
abgesagt
das ist die große frage sprechen gerne
mal ein paar leuten aber auch hier in
berlin da diese märchen für den
überquellenden die intensivstation das
ist doch alles teil der angstmacherei
der über sterblichkeit wenn wir jetzt
noch gar nicht so gemeint aber dass
die krankheit zu gravierend ist die
überheblichkeit hatte so langer zeit
üblich gegeben es ist heute in die igeho
studie die heute veröffentlicht wurde
frankfurter allgemeine ich bin alter
mann ich lese man tag schon wieder der
eigentlichen zur stadt zeitung wird sie
dann die wahrheit drin so und wenn ich
die nzz lese stelle ich fest dass eben
diese messdaten die angelegt werden und
die selbst oder den fachleuten wie er
nun mal wieder ohne frage einer ist sehr
umstritten sind deswegen möchte ich auch
sagen ich bin weder arzt noch ihre logo
aber ich bin bürger und steuerzahler und
beobachte diese gesamte kampagne und
fühle mich total verkohlt ich bin vom
ersten tag an belogen wurden durch die
politik und durch leute die spende
vertreter sind alle die hier sitzen
welchen weiß ich nicht vertreten die
bestimmte institutionen das sind
lobbyisten der seiner partei muss wieder
aufgestellt sein wahlkreis und das
mutige weg man sagen herzlich mit ihm
umgeht aber ich habe mich immer
interessiert sein
aber die fakten kleinen als solo greift
bei den sechsten so kley nicht sagen
dass er menschen die eine andere meinung
haben schauen sie mal ich habe ein
freiwilliger für ein amerikanisches
magazin live sendung beobachtet einen
will fernsehen in deutschland
die zwei drittel davon waren niemals
eingeladen ein wissenschaftler der nicht
die gleiche meinung das war wie ein chor
gesang thomas thumann o kurs am ende
haben sich die hände gehalten wir haben
uns alle lieb erst nach und nach oder
der neue hamburger eingeladen und der
bonner es ist eine bevölkerung ein
bisschen ganzen ich glaube um eine w2
analysieren brauchen wenn ich gar nicht
sagen wie die kritische stimmen
konsequent ausgegrenzt und sie sind
davon wollen dann waren's rassist
und hermann den herbstschauen wir
bleiben
wir hier vor all meinen respekt bei
verdacht auf vermeidung die vielleicht
nicht die eigenen sind deswegen ich bin
sehr wichtig je sagen also wir sind
zurzeit in einer ausgesprochen guten
situation die zahlen sinken die
infektionszahlen die belebung der
krankenhäuser sind wir ärzte haben jetzt
die verpflichtung dafür zu sorgen dass
das durch den herbst hindurch trägt
unsere aufgabe ist es auch die
bevölkerung darauf vorzubereiten was
passieren kann wenn wir glück haben dass
hier gar nichts dann sind wir alle
zufrieden da haben wir als erster auch
unsere aufgabe bestens erfüllt aber wir
müssen einfach davor warnen dass es aus
dem normalen virus geschehen heraus
möglichkeit gibt dass sich die situation
im herbst wieder verschlimmert und dann
haben wir wieder die politische
diskussion damit haben wir erzeugen ist
gar nichts zu tun die politische
diskussion kontakt beschränkungen masken
pflichte finde ich die dann sehr wäre
und auch noch mal wieder über die
impfpflicht deswegen sagen wir heute
impfen impfen testen testen testen und
beim testen vor allem auch checken ob da
neue variationen neue mutationen wieder
vorkommen aber wir wissen eines wer
geimpft ist wer drei mal geimpft es am
besten er hat heute sein risiko an der
erkrankung zu versterben um 99 prozent
das ist eine fantastische zahl gibt es
wird nicht bei der grippeimpfung kann es
nur 50 prozent gibt es bei bestimmten
vorgängen bei denen bei denen das virus
sich nicht verändert wie zum beispiel
masern aber wer das tut der hat eine
gute chance und deswegen müssen wir die
impf kampagne forcieren wir müssen das
testen machen und wir müssen hoffen dass
es nicht zu einer variation und mutation
kommt da gibt's dann so mal läuten die
laufen rum und behaupten das sich im
laufe von mutationen die videos qualität
einfach vielleicht das ist falsch das
land steht im lehrbuch das ist ein
absoluter mir ist völliger unsinn und
das wird immer wiederholt lesen sie
einfach mal die arbeiten dazu hast und
lehrbücher ausgetragen werden
jahrhundert und dann werden sie die
fakten zur kenntnis also wenn das stimmt
was sie sagt ist er seltsam dass selbst
die impfquote beachten in keiner weise
geimpfte weniger versterben wie
ungeimpfte das ist einfach fakt aber
jetzt will ich will das einfach ich will
das kleine geschenke geschenk ich will
aufs andere geschenk danke dann ich
arbeite in wissenschaftlichen leitlinien
setzen experten zusammen gegen bestimmte
regeln eingehalten und da muss man
einfach das pferd von vorne und nicht
von hinten aufzäumen und wir müssen mal
überlegen was ist denn eigentlich das
ziel der ganzen maßnahmen was war denn
das ziel gewesen das war durch die
überlastung der krankenhäuser zu
verhindern und wir wissen doch dass das
niemals der fall war dass die überlastet
waren es steht seit april 19
2021 auf der homepage des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums da steht
die leipzig untersuchung der bbe
lebenssituation
2020 wortwörtlich kann der zuschauer
auch nachprüfen da steht es war noch nie
so eine tiefe belegung in den
krankenhäusern historisch unterbelegt
auch die intensiv abteilungen 16 prozent
weniger belegung im vergleich zu 2009/10
es waren das war die pandemie die leeren
betten und die krankenhäuser
transportiert und jetzt kommt aber die
preisfrage jetzt kommt die angst
wenn ich eine aussehen würde war ein hat
ja ungefähr parteien inhalts jetzt kommt
die wichtigste sei
jetzt kommen die wichtigste zahl der
gesamten corona krise jetzt kommt die
wichtigste zahl und ich möchte gern
wissen ob sie die kennen wie viel
prozent dieser schon unterbelegung hat
in den krankenhäusern die diagnose
kurven zu bekommen wissen sie es für
hier keine statistik herr amthor sie
beschließen gesetze
infektionsschutzgesetzes beschließen
sie haben dazu erst erkennen sind
gemeinsam einen idealen sie kennen die
wichtigste zahl nicht die die einfach
zeigt ob mir ein großes problem hatten
oder nicht kennen sie die tat also diese
zahl ist völlig bedeutungslos weil die
fakt ist dass wir heute den menschen die
in den intensivstationen gearbeitet
haben über ein pflege bonus reden weil
die sind am ende das ist ein pflege
jüdischer staffelhighlight ich hab ja
doch recht rausreden dass ich will
wissen ob sie die zeiten können wir
nicht sagen nach einer rede über die
wichtigsten zahlen
minute endlich mal über ein jahr mit ist
das ganz was anderes sein nein das ist
ja das stimmt auch nicht sagen einmal
die zahl herr frank 2 prozent und die
kleinen prozent was ist die quelle
dieser zahl die kennen sie nicht das ist
die auftrag des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums
an das leipziger institut seit einem
jahr steht die zahl auf der homepage 2
im schnitt und auf intensiv dreieck
firma 4% wo ist denn da das problem also
dass wir das eben sagen das problem ist
darin dass wir in den intensiv dazu wir
haben intensiv register der ddr wissen
sie vielleicht dass wir zeitweise am
obersten rande der beläge und nicht die
ganze zeit nicht ein ganzes jahr
hindurch aber zeitweise so dass wir
deswegen die bundeswehr geholt haben um
mit magic flugzeugen menschen innerhalb
deutschlands von einer intensiven
gesprächen der eu ist es noch nie
passiert mit der verlegung von patienten
aber nicht
wir haben wir haben mit den meriva
fliegern bei ebola leute aus den
regionen afrika nach deutschland während
die
intensivbetten abgebaut in deutschland
zieht das sagen sie also
so schön die
zahlen des bundesgesundheitsministeriums
es war nie ein problem es gibt immer
punktuell überbelegungen es gab immer
freie betten es steht wortwörtlich herr
montgomery sie kennen das nicht so schön
eine panik im herbst und sie dass dies
ähnliche waren ein faktencheck ja sage
ich erhielt daher und dann zeigen wir
das
gerne zahl stimmt bestimmt ob die
rückschlüsse daraus richtig sind ist die
nächste frage wenn man jetzt mal das
bescheidene bild eines nicht mediziner
sondern eines wahlkreisabgeordneten
sieht es genau das so wie es herr
montgomery beschrieben hat wir haben
über den jahreswechsel letztes jahr das
erste mal erlebt dass ihm ein kleines
bescheidenes krankenhaus in meiner
heimatstadt ueckermünder aus der
universitätsmedizin greifswald verlegt
werden musste als erste mal in der
geschichte weil maximalversorger
universitätskliniken voll waren in den
intensivstationen meine kleine regionale
krankenhäuser alle mit
personalproblemen fünf euro sondern eben
auch ohne das ist doch völlig winterthur
also es ist wahnsinn dass ich leute ja
eher regel zumindest sollte man das kann
natürlich sein dass alle anderen blöd
sind und diese eine schlüsselzahl nicht
erkannt haben ich würde jetzt mal sagen
es spricht viel dafür dass man die von
herrn montgomery angeführten zahlen eben
auch ernst nimmt und ich gucke mir das
gerne an aber die eine zauber zahl die
jetzt sozusagen die mehrzahl der
wissenschaft in sich zusammenfallen
lässt das finde ich dann doch sehr
überrascht ist die ideale form doch die
realität sie reden über modellrechnungen
ich rede über die messungen der kogit
patienten in den deutschen
krankenhäusern und die war bei
unterbelegung 2 prozent im schnitt und
das ist fakt und davon muss man ausgehen
und deswegen ist die ganze panikmache
durch diese zahl wieder lebendig heute
schon mit der zahl ran um jetzt der
frage müssen wir einen was
wegbleiben regionalität immer eine
spannende frage bleibt aber natürlich
und die möchte ich gerne herr amt
vorstellen ob man nicht doch man merkt
ja redebedarf es da in der bevölkerung
braucht man vielleicht ein crooner
untersuchungsausschuss wo genau alles
mal durchdekliniert und durch wir haben
einen corona begleit gremium eingesetzt
das sich genau mit diesen fragen
beschäftigt richtig ist und das muss man
schon mal sagen die politische
diskussion darum ist ja nicht beendet es
war richtig dass die impfpflicht keinen
halt machen wir mussten jetzt aber schon
sehen und das war auch heute bei uns ein
thema im innenausschuss haben wir
natürlich auch gefragt wie bereitet man
sich denn jetzt auf den herbst vor was
sind die überlegung und wir haben ja
sehr gesagt man muss damit man eben
fakten und evidenzbasiert entscheidet
auch wissen was die lage ist wir haben
ja gefordert dass wir über es ins
register zum beispiel mal reden die
bundesregierung schläft macht nichts
also die haben ja auf den letzten metern
damit scholz und lauterbach ihre
mehrheit kriegen haben sie haben gesagt
sie sind auch für einen priester
vorbereitet wird jetzt gar nichts und
ich sehe es auch dass die
bundesregierung das jetzt einfach laufen
lässt und dann kommt nachher die
überraschung dass man nicht vorbereitet
war das ist jetzt die zeit dafür aber es
muss eben auch ein blick nach vorne
gehen und die rückspiegel diskussion
wissen sie jetzt kommt ihre aber der
rückstand ist an spielen auf der
homepage
ich bin ich höre auf den namen merkel
nicht
also ich bin es auf der homepage des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums ja wie auf
seite 4 leipzig analyse
unter berücksichtigung befreien wollen
wurde die belegen um -16 prozent
zurückgefahren auch auf intensiv dies
berücksichtigt bereits sicher so und so
weiter im jahresschnitt
die belegung 2 prozent aller betten und
4 prozent aller intensivbetten für die
diagnose kubis will das höchst absolut
der realität von menschen die man im
krankenhaus waren zu denen ich gehöre
die sich das mal angeguckt haben sie
gesehen haben was unsere mitarbeiter
dort arbeiten was sie leisten was sie
jeden tag leisten weswegen wir ihnen am
anfang vom abt vom vom balkon aus
applaudiert haben und jetzt am ende ein
pflege bonus zahlt man streiten können
wir uns eben nicht in den hintern tritt
wundern und acht ein quadband sicht
versucht man ja wirklich diesen menschen
auch mehr schutz zu geben für sich
selber und auch für ihre patienten sich
vor allem natürlich nicht vorbei die die
zwei werden sie nachher an alle hier
teilen wir werden alle rum schenken dann
macht hermann gommel nochmal den
faktencheck haben traurig guckt mir auch
an und damit kommen wir aber jetzt erst
mal zu ihrem thema was auch eins ist was
wirklich die nation auch spaltet kann
man ganz klar sagen es tut mir leid über
die heftigkeit in der diskussion aber
das ist einfach wichtig weil es man muss
wenn man wissenschaftlich argumentiert
von vorne beginnen von der basis wenn
nicht stimmt und wir hatten keine
überbelegung wir hatten keine probleme
das ist fakt und jetzt deswegen ist es
von vornherein als problematisch an den
impfstoff der experimentell ist und eine
große medizinische leistung mit einer
bedingten zulassung dann loszulassen und
jetzt müssen wir die bedingte zu lassen
sich anschauen darf eu ebene was steht
drin das muss ganz engmaschig
kontrolliert werden die nationalstaaten
müssen an die eu die daten engmaschig
liefern das macht die bundesregierung
überhaupt nicht sie leben das geregelt
recht ab und es muss im beipackzettel
und jeden patienten und jede
medizinische personal ganz klar gemacht
werden es handelt sich um eine bedingte
zulassung sprich die die 2000 studien
sind nicht abgeschlossen und wenn man
das bedenkt und wenn man die warnungen
bedenkt die dann auch mit den im leben
wirkungen schon früh geäußert wurden und
dann zieht was jetzt los ist ich habe
täglich patienten mit schweren
nebenwirkungen
ich gebe zu das ist selektiv weil
natürlich die leute extra deswegen auch
wissen dass ich ihnen zuhöre weil sie
werden nämlich von ihren ärzten nicht
ernst genommen und das sind heute ich
füge kein komma zu ein junger mann 20
jahre alt nach der ersten impfung
schlecht geschlafen da der arzt gesagt
ich verschreibe mal ein
beruhigungsmittel zweiten von vier
wochen später
schwerste auch ein problem er hat eine
ausbildung angefangen zum fahrlehrer
musste er abbrechen dann ging das zwei
monate später los mit mit mit schwäche
des arms dann nach einigen monaten
konnte er nicht mehr richtig laufen der
rennt von pontius zu pilatus ist kriegt
einen termin in der neuromuskulären
ambulanz im dezember 2022
kein arzt nimmt ihn ernst und das ist
kein einzelfall ich tausche mich aus mit
mit ärzten die sich dem thema öffnen und
sie erleben dass genau das gleiche und
wir haben inzwischen ja auch weil
deutschland keine vernünftige
wissenschaft hinkriegt aber ich muss
sagen die studie von herrn matheis ist
nun mal das einzige was mir einigermaßen
vernünftig haben und da kommt eine zahl
heraus die international ja auch
bestätigt ist von 0,8 prozent pro
impfung schwere nebenwirkungen ja und
dann wirkt die finger gar nicht
definieren sie haben nicht zugehört
ich hab's gesehen hat gesagt es geht um
schwere neben hat er gesagt es ist aber
nicht verstanden das können wir uns auch
angucken er hat schwere nebenwirkung
gesagt ja er hat sie gesagt aber sind
keine schwere leben das er hat sich eine
internationale definiert er hat
definiert mit arztbesuch mehrere tage
krank und so weiter ich kenne ich habe
seit 30 jahren im fisch aber ist und ich
hab so was nur bei der krone empfang
gibt es nicht bei jeder in science
nebenwirkungen natürlich gibt es dir die
einheit aber wir haben sie haben jetzt
schon bei der zahl von pro forma
baulichen zu die nur die meldet sie von
haben wir 0,02 aber das sind ingesamt
zahlen so viel dass jedes normal
zugelassene medikament eigentlich schon
die zulassung gestunken heil das ist
aber wir haben den faktor und 40
inzwischen also und ich kann wirklich
die verantwortung an den appellieren
leute ihr müsst die zulassung ruhen
lassen um die eminenten
sicherheitsfragen zu klären und nochmal
deutschland kommt zu einer pflicht nicht
hinterher selbst im
infektionsschutzgesetz steht dass die
kassenärztliche vereinigungen die die
impf daten liefern müssen sie tun es
nicht so jetzt wäre das verdammt werden
ich gehe jetzt mal ein paar sachen sagen
er sie als die zulassungsstudien sind
nicht sind längst abgeschlossen und die
begann die bedingte zulassung ist darauf
zurückzuführen dass man die
zulassungsstudien parallel zur zulassung
bereits begleitet was ungewöhnlich 2021
haben und da wir jetzt mal einmal
ausgang nicht zu fassen so dass das
zweite das zweite es sind inzwischen
zwölf milliarden impfdosen weltweit
vergeben worden wo sind die vielen neben
wirkungsmächtig wirklich mal wissen
drittens glauben sie denn dass alle
ärzte ihre kollegen meine kollegen die
leute immer alle nicht ernst nehmen nein
es gibt bestimmte ärzte die ein gewisses
charisma darin haben solche dinge
anzuziehen und die welschen besonders
ernst zu nehmen schließlich die
impfstudie von herrn mattes die ist gar
nicht abgeschlossen die charité ist im
höchsten maße entsetzt darüber dass ist
entspricht widerspricht jedem
wissenschaftlichen standard dass man
eine studie die noch gar nicht
abgeschlossen geschweige denn
ausgewertet ist bereits publizistisch in
der frage um die impfpflicht benutzt und
gar nicht sagt er zur gefahr in verzug
naturkunde sehen also gefahr im verzug
wie einimpfen immer noch täglich mehrere
zig bis 100.000 menschen dann als die im
als die infektionszahlen höher waren und
wir sehen eben nicht diese
nebenwirkungen im bereich der seriösen
wissenschaftlichen ich habe mich eine
reiterin veränderungs gesprochen der hat
der advent im zentrum geleitet nach der
ersten impfung anstieg der leberenzyme
hat sich schlecht gefühlt verriet ihn
hoch runter zweiten vergleichen und dann
ist ja kein zufall er krank oder gibt es
wirklich die breite der vorder und die
kausalität ist außerdem ein währungs
große in meiner sicht sehr gut rein ich
bin sehr gut vernetzt mit mit wirklich
führenden epidemiologen nichts zu melden
haben in dieser ganzen grummeln israel
matthias schrappe das ist gerd anders
und ich sagen von anfang an wir haben
überhaupt keine erfassung werden wir
lassen die leute blind ins messer laufen
wir kümmern uns überhaupt nicht um
irgendwelche hatten datenerhebungen und
ncl mattes zu diskreditieren der als
erster jetzt mal versucht da irgendwie
licht ins dunkel zu bringen wie ein
starkes stück wo sind bitteschön die
untersuchungen zeigen dass diese diese
impfnebenwirkungen marginal sind also
der frage und sehr viel darüber einig
dass es nicht wissenschaftlicher
standard ist eine studie die noch nicht
abgeschlossen ist und die noch gar nicht
ausgewertet worden ist rein empirisch
irgendwie irgendwas dazu zu sagen wenn
eine zahl zu konstruieren wie 0,8 warten
wir doch mal ab was rauskommt wenn diese
studie zu ende ist und wenn sie aus
geworden und sie müssen darüber hinaus
auch wissen das ist keine studie kein
sogenanntes randomisiert das prospektive
untersuchung sondern das ist der dritte
an menschen sich zu melden ob sie impfen
warum habe ich tu dir nicht herr
montgomery event dieser verdacht die
haben da hast du dir wir haben nicht
fertig ausgewertet nein ich habe direkt
eine frage an sängerfrauen zwar haben
sie denn als bürger bedenken gehabt oder
haben sie sich impfen lassen wie stehen
sie denn zu nehmen also ich bin ein
treuer deutsche staatsbürger meine
eltern sind auch uralt deutsche von
daher bin ich natürlich ließ der befehl
verlangt drei mal impfen gegangen habe
mich auch bewusst und lassen entgegen
der empfehlung von freunden von mir die
ärzte sind und habe jetzt alles getan
und man amerikanischen freunden von
denen ich viele habe die mich ja gerade
haben macht das nicht und habe da ich
wohl corona bekommen soviel dazu ich
weiß nicht also in zukunft nicht mehr
impfen weil in der abwägung der
impfrisiken gegen die tatsache durch ein
crooner trotz impfung bekommen habe hat
mich irgendwie meinen etwas aufgewühlt
aber ich möchte eigentlich zwei andere
fragen stellen die ich heute morgen
schon mal überlegt haben den bettchen
noch dann ich bin ich froh das darf und
es war ist die eine frage ist ich bin
nie klar geworden über jahre höre ich
den subjektiven deutschlandfunk
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk nicht
über dich reden wollen willkommen ich
meine lesung und unter anderem war über
monate wie der wehrmachts bericht früher
waren die berichte über die kunert sein
und dann hörte ich immer mit und an
corona der eigenen verstorben das ist
ein mit und was ist denn an entweder
harter corona oder ist ein mit groner
oder an was gestorben sie haben eben die
wissenschaft bemüht wie wollen sie denn
zu klaren ergebnissen kommen ihr die
hand oder mit gestanden wir ja wie wir
das ist die kleine schar können dich
jeden patienten der an koan oder mit
corinna stirbt obduzieren das heißt also
schön dass wir vergeben die warte mal es
gibt aber untersuchungen die das ganz
klar beweisen und so gibt es zum
beispiel im bereich der justiz klinik
hamburg barsbüttel und anderem eine
studie gemacht 1000 in hamburg
gestorbenen menschen zu 85 prozent sind
die anwohner die während zu dem
zeitpunkt nicht gestorben wenn sie nicht
krone gab hätten das natürlich diese
menschen auch andere erkrankungen haben
das ist eine andere kiste aber wir sind
doch nicht so zynisch dass wir sagen
also du hast jetzt schon eine andere
krankheit ist ein stück banken aber vor
sich sondern noch
ausgesetzt sind handel bringen aber dann
kommt doch jetzt kommt auch kein text an
es kommt auf den kontext an
ich habe
meine fragen ausstellen die mich bewegt
sich hier ein schon dadurch können sie
nicht verantworten so über dich dann tue
so also die frage ist wieso die haben
gesprochen von den zuständen auf den
stationen ich habe eine sehr gute
bekannte diese ob er die schwester in
der charité auf einer intensivstation
und wissen sie was mich umgehauen hat
die lässt sich nicht impfen wie haben
wir eine situation dass die die
unmittelbar konfrontiert sind mit dieser
heimsuchung haben dass diese leute die
nun wirklich zittern von 1 der fall sein
der mitarbeiter und da hat man in
italien und die frage reicht das ist
eine sehr klare regel gebrochen hat
diesen menschen hat diese menschen in
andere bereiche oder ihnen das
arbeitsleben ich hatte heute ein motto
wir haben weiter gar nicht hat er heuer
haben sich im feuchten das ist nämlich
irgendwann die vernunft und der verstand
ein lassen sie mich ja aber verloren und
das verbraucht zwar aber nicht so dass
man sich der verloren sport warum gerade
in denen einer so im kreis ja ich hatte
eine schwester
die genau sich aus diesem grund nicht
impfen ist weil sie sagt sie sieht das
eben vermehrt junge die er nie von coop
19 bedruckt sind das ist ja auch das
problem wenn wir bei der impfung über
die risikogruppen sprechen dann können
wir darüber sprechen aber doch nicht
bittet die überhaupt nicht vom kurs 19
bedroht bedroht sind dann müssen wir
doch jetzt stoppen und diese schwester
hat jetzt gekündigt weil sie nachts
nicht mehr mit vermischen und wir müssen
einfach mal die gesamtzahlen
gesamtzahlen sehen sie haben aber über
sterblichkeit gesprochen da kann man es
natürlich lange diskutieren wie
ermittelt man über sterblichkeit aber
wenn sie das prozentual nehmen dann
sehen sie dass 2020 im vergleich zu den
einzel jahren hing ein günstiges
sterbejahr war muss man sagen
2021 jedoch im zweiten jahreshälfte ging
das los und das betrifft die jüngeren
jahrgänge das sind fakten das kann ich
ihnen auch leicht belegen also wir haben
hier kein über sterblichkeits problem
gehabt 2020 aber wir fangen mit 2021
zweite jahreshälfte mit an bei jüngeren
die und da ist ich sage nicht dass das
die impfung ist aber da die kampagne
angefangen bei den jüngeren und es
müssen wir untersuchen und wenn herr
mattes diese meldungen gibt dann machte
er nicht weil er jetzt sagt das ist die
fertige studie sondern sagt ist es
gefahr in verzug wir müssen das thema
jetzt diskutieren und ich appelliere an
alle die irgendwie verantwortung tragen
bitte machen sie nicht so weiter wird
bevor wir nicht wirklich die sache
sauber untersucht haben können wir nicht
wieder diese panik schüren leute ihnen
in die impfung brauchen ihn stoppen oder
was ist
demnach alle menschen verbieten also hat
nach allen seriösen kriterien hat muss
die bedingte zulassung gestoppt werden
die sicherheitsfragen geklärt das impfen
also wollen sie ihre skis halte ich für
sie setzten die seriosität der kriterien
weil ich die thüringer gegen gesamte
seriöse wissenschaftler sharing oder
mannschaft kommt
ich habe
gerade die wichtigste zeigen hat und sie
haben sie nicht gekanntes
disqualifiziert sie beide muss ich ihnen
ganz klar sagen
dass uns das ist ja eh wir reden also 2
prozent hinterher weil sonst stoff
bereits fenster da von anfang an den
nicht fertig habe ich habe ihn bei
patienten in der risikogruppe
anfangsverdacht und dann habe ich mich
da nie damit befasst und habe mich dann
entschlossen nicht mehr zu kämpfen weil
ich kann dies nicht verantworten und ich
habe auch heute erlebt dass die ganz
viele viele kollegen leider den leuten
nicht gesagt haben das ist eine bedingte
zulassung ist und damit nicht regulär
und die zulassungsstudie haben und
comrie 1300 bis
2023 heimischen genauso habe ich diese
83 raten die jeder ausfüllen und seine
geimpft wird in denen der patient
darüber aufgeklärt wird und sogar
unterschreiben muss dass er das weiß
also die sie haben das doch selbst bei
ihren patienten hoffentlich gemacht weil
ja die haben mir sogar einen haken diese
besondere zeit geschrieben ich habe die
der halbe stunde und erklärt sehr gut
und im impfzentrum haben sich weil sie
kümmert waren trotzdem impfen lassen ja
und das ist ja daraus wolfen hat es auf
3060 wir haben heute glaube ich bei 1700
auf der spitze der letzten welle 2007
wurden leitzins idente hatte eine irre
hohen inzidenz sagt doch dann haben wir
gesagt dass wir noch mal zu haben wir
doch weniger weniger tote gehabt als wir
bei 150 incident radtour vor dem jahr
davor gehabt sie haben 2001 war
auswerten sie haben 2000 als einen
ausdruck der impfung und ist außerdem
organisieren könnte ich ja wir können
über die religiösen gesetzten gewöhnen
wir haben 30 anzeiger wir können über
wir können über die risikogruppen
sprechen aber was unterhalb der
risikogruppen abläuft halte ich für eine
fehlleistung die können sich als die
größte seit bestehen da unsere
herausschlagen
können ja sie als steuerzahler das
gleiche frage stellen sich schon
angemeldet habe er gar freigegeben einen
ganz kurzen unterbrechungen sind dann
wieder zurück bin der steuerzahler ja
das haben wir jetzt auch noch verkündet
wie wir alle
viel wieder zurück bis gleich
[Musik]
also da kann ich dann ein lauter krach
und nicht ernst nehmen als sogenannten
experten
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren ball fehlte der 85 köpfen und
meinungen von jeder von uns hat ein
thema mitgebracht was ihn bewegt freut
oder schockiert
[Musik]
so nicht über chip buschi hergiswil
wetten seit august aber niemand von den
politischen parteien traut sich zu sagen
ja das wollen hier einfach nur freiheit
diese grün-roten der darin führen hoch
graben der debatten über die rettung des
weltklimas und um die füße russen die
ratten das thema ist viel zu wichtig um
es nur der ard zu überlassen lasst den
leuten sondern spaß wir sehen da etwas
was eigentlich fatale ist in der politik
bei den journalisten deren job ist es
doch gerade abweichende meinungen zu
finden und sie sollen den doch auch
richtig
dass conti zum manko bleibt einmal kurz
doch das sind übliche anorak träger
ausgeschrieben ist ich habe meinen
beifahrer meine sache immer bekommt er
kümmert sich darum niemand bitten
man ist ja ganz knapp drüber sprechen
das ist ein fakt nicht fertig richtig
durch die ausgabe von journalismus
einfach die verlautbarungen der politik
zu hinterfragen
[Musik]
sie wenn sie ja
herzlich willkommen zurück schön dass
sie dran geblieben sind es wird jetzt
weiter hoch hergehen und
leidenschaftlich debattiert werden wie
immer bei 48 und zwar mit dem thema von
herta frau was er heute mitgebracht hat
sind wir gleich da kann ich ja gleich
anschließenden das werde ich noch fragen
wollte ich bin ein verwunderter
zeitungsleser nicht gestern wie man
sieht nicht als gestern geboren und auch
nicht mit dem kleinen finger gemacht
deswegen stelle ich immer noch eine
frage hinderte frage ganz naiv könnte es
nicht sein dass so viel impfstoff
gekauft wurde dass man vielleicht eines
tages rechtfertigen muss wie viel mittel
aufgewandt wurden und wer da verdient
hat und dass man deswegen das auf teufel
komm raus
kämpfen muss und vielleicht fließende
auf provisionen die irgendwann mal
ich habe hier eine frage nicht
dass sie das problem sie denn das ist so
ganz klarer ich wollte das nur sagen
diese frage treibt mich halt um wie
viele andere menschen in unserem lande
ich mich zeit um ich bin da wirklich
sehr bewusst über ein umstand dass etwas
mit gerechtigkeit mit
steuergerechtigkeit zu tun wir haben in
der bundesrepublik deutschland ich freue
mich eine kfz steuer damit man weiß was
das ist die wurde in deutschland
eingeführt 1899 im übrigen 13 jahre
nachdem zum ersten mal ein tuk tuk
gerollt ist ja das wurde dies aber als
luxussteuer apostrophiert 899 im
regierungsbezirk hessen-darmstadt dass
man nur zur kenntnis diese steuer wird
in der bundesrepublik erhoben und ist
ein zwölfter stelle sein name vermögens
der im steueraufkommen an zwölfter
stelle sind im jahr etwa 915 milliarden
euro 60 millionen fahrzeuge sind in der
bundesrepublik deutschland der alter kfz
steuerpflichtig 60 millionen und es soll
ist es keine zweckgebundene
steuervergehen im bundeshaushalt auf
aber ursprünglich war mal die idee dass
sie eigentlich
die kassette leute das strahlt dem er
all der straßen und dem autofahren der
instandhaltung von straßen und ähnlichen
lass mich ausreden januar war sie machen
einfach die spitzen schon immer das also
ist ich halte ihn sie wieder mehr keine
veruntreuung veruntreuung von
steuergeldern die autofahrer finanzieren
das zubauen von staaten die berliner
innenstadt friedrichstraße gleicht heute
in dem hunde friedhof von chicago wo das
lebendiger werden sie wir versinken
unsere innenstädte im grabesstille wir
machen busspuren die radfahrer fahren
und durch die gegend rall album dann
sollen sie verdammt noch mal auch mit
ein stück verantwortung übernehmen denn
wir räumen ihn ja ich fahre öffentlich
sie denken nicht vorstellen nein ich
fahre pnv tut ob es beim u bahn und so
japan hätten menschen hier sind und bin
also in einer situation dass ich mich
frage wieso müssen meine ganzen reichen
freunde die haben nur so träume zahlen
viel steuern wieso müssen die bezahlen
das die wirklich rüpelhafte radfahrer
weil sie sich ideologisch als moralisch
besser fühlen durch die gegend in das
zweite sich versuchen möchte eine
versicherungspflicht zu hart war die
radfahrer verursachen bei
personenschaden um fällen
63.500 im jahr jeder zweite unfall mit
personenschaden an dem ein radfahrer
verurteilt beteiligt ist wurde durch den
radfahrer verursacht
statistisches bundesamt wiesbaden
innenministerium bonn nachprüfbar keine
frage rufen sie an die können die zahlen
alle vorlegen
ich möchte eine versicherungspflicht
haben denn die fußgänger das sind es 75
prozent wenn fahrradfahrer schuld sind
haben keine möglichkeiten den täter zu
verfolgen ich habe in meinem
bekanntenkreis leute die sich die
scheibe gebrochen der zahl der ist
eigentlich die farm davon und sagen
timpe hier also machen die stinkefinger
verstehen sie und deswegen ist das
ungerecht dass leute die kfz steuer
zahlen und die straßen umgebaut werden
zu toten fragen so abend erwarten denn
dadurch soll also erstmal zur
versicherungspflicht und das wäre nur
eine fahrradfahrer schützende sache denn
der fahrradfahrer haftet natürlich heute
schon
wieder aber das lösen sie nicht tue ich
das problem der versicherungspflicht
also erstens muss man sagen der
fahrradfahrer hatten verrechnung
ausgesetzt und die versicherungspflicht
nur dass er als verstehen und zum anlass
gut zu seinem thema steuern ist es
hoffentlich so dass wir ja beide
freilich steuer liberale politiker sind
die erstmal verstehen dass eine steuer
und das ist das was mich an dem konzept
ein bisschen stört eigentlich am steuer
eine finanzierungsfunktion für den staat
und mir geht offen gesprochen auf den
senkel dass wir ohnehin versuchen über
steuern permanent verhaltenssteuerung
herbeizuführen so waren sehr sauer ja
finde ich aber auch nicht gerade
und deswegen ziehe ich eine
grundstruktur dass man immer jetzt
fragen sollte ob man das noch
verschlimmbessert wenn man sagt man will
jetzt ein rad fahren besteuern wollen
sie damit eine lenkungswirkung im
prinzip der irgendein herzlichkeit
mitwirkung nein ich finde das ist macht
sozusagen das system noch schiefer indem
sie sagen jetzt sozusagen wird eine
steuerungerechtigkeit durch die nächste
angriff ja das ist so ich halte das für
eine schweinerei und
ich würde halt sagen wir kämpfen so nie
lösen die probleme jetzt nicht indem wir
versuchen das menschliche verhalten
durch immer mehr steuersituation
aufzublähen sondern am ende müssen wir
schon schauen und da sind wir uns glaube
ich eine last sein wir wollen die
leistungsverweigerer ich würde sagen wir
müssen schon schauen dass wir und das
klang ja auch an in ihren argumenten
dass wir schon auch gucken müssen dass
wir nicht diesen ideologischen kampf
gegen das auto führen das ist ja richtig
glaube das ist so das war es ein
bisschen aus dem herzen kommt gerade als
jemand aus dem ländlichen raum sage ich
das auch klar wir müssen da verschiedene
lebensrealitäten auch aufpassen aber ich
glaube jetzt jedenfalls durch das thema
steuern gesellschaftspolitische probleme
zu lösen dann bin ich immer als
wirtschaftsliberaler politiker es finde
sich daraus winden sich auf
ordnungspolitik ab ja und ist doch aber
richtig ich weiß nicht was sich
anhört wie eine der besten größten
gruppen im lande nämlich die autofahrer
in jeder hinsicht sein soll man es von
jedem liter benzin der weshalb wird 60
prozent nichts mit autofahren mit
menschen probleme mit blick auf doppel
konnten
er soll nicht besser wieder erfahren hat
steuerlich nicht absetzen ich denke ich
bin ich bin senkung des steuerdrucks
stolz gewesen war wirklich passionierte
autofahrer und fahrradfahrer ich ihnen
heute ich bin heute diese vater
friedrich straße entlang gefahren so
wunderbar darum dass daraus rheintal
brauchen sie das braucht die
prinzessin ich finde haben dort mit
einer sache völlig recht ist ist auch
heute schon so dass das hier hab dich
für sicherheit sein müssen oder eine
vielzahl
privater sie stehen jetzt in der pflicht
haben dann müssen halt eine pflicht
verfahren also wissen sie was so wissen
sie wo und wissen sie was dann gibt es
einen teil der bevölkerung der aufzeigt
und an der alten teil der 400 laufen
darf oder nicht geld für die
zusagen über steuern löse ich das jetzt
mal also ist so typisch grüne starts
regular
season
in diesem kontext wirklich beneide ich
die schweiz oder dänemark die haben
diese völlig übertriebene corona history
erkannt haben die maßnahmen komplett
abgestellt
der rote bereich und den nebenreihen
eigentlich jetzt ich wünsche nicht so
dass ich werde ohne nicht wäre schon ein
wenn ich wäre schon sehr gut ich wäre
schon längst fertig wenn ich dürfte
genau und tun jetzt nachbereiten
überprüfen was war sinnvoll was er
übertrieben was ihr nicht gemacht wird
und können sich jetzt solchen themen
widmen ja das ist doch wunderbar wenn
wir die gesellschaft werden wo man über
solche die mir sprechen themen reden sie
mal den neuer staatsverdrossenheit ja
dass ich etwas erzählen aber dagegen gar
nicht aber wir sind wisse dass wir uns
nicht mehr als terroristen beschimpft
darum sage ich es warum das man nicht
mehr leute also zahlen nennen weil sie
einfach angst vor einem neuen medikament
haben sondern dass wir über fahrräder
diskutieren sowas würde ich mir wieder
zurückwünschen jetzt haben wir gerade
erlebt und jetzt kommen wir zu einem
thema was für eine antwort mitgebracht
hat und was glaube ich viel mehr auf uns
alle bewegt als fahrrad steigen mögliche
ja so ist es denn wenn man darüber redet
was die menschen derzeit am meisten
bewegt dann ist es natürlich im moment
die inflation dann ist es die
wirtschaftliche lage in unserem land wir
haben die höchste inflation seit 40
jahren und das stören die bürger das
stören sie an der tankstelle der spüren
sie im supermarkt und langfristig hat
das natürlich auch folgen für die
altersvorsorge für die ganze vermögens
ordnung in unserem land und deswegen ist
es auch eines der schwerpunktthemen dass
wir in dieser woche im deutschen
bundestag besprechen und die ampel hat
dafür jetzt ihre großen vorschläge
vorgelegt und da muss man sagen sie
gehen nicht weit genug sondern sie
setzen an der falschen stelle an die
grünen haben mal versprochen
bürgerenergie geld für alle daraus ist
jetzt geworden ein in eine energie
pauschale für weniger für wenige schüler
gehen studenten gehen leer aus rentner
gehen leer aus das ist ein system das im
moment nicht zusammenpasst und die ampel
hat mit dem neuen euro ticket und
anderen projekten
individuelles klein klein gemacht aber
die großen themen die werden nicht
angepackt die kalte progression die
steuerbelastung das ist im moment das
thema wir brauchen einen
inflationsschutz schirm der muss jetzt
aufgespannt werden und das kleinklein
der ampel geht da einfach nicht weiter
und wenn ich da eigentlich nur anknüpfen
dürfte haben dort völlig recht die
inflation ist das größte and reichs
mittel vor allem für arme leute ja das
ist einfach des unsozialen ohne ende
muss etwas dagegen tun für mich noch aus
dem parteipolitischen geplänkel
heraushalten würde aber auch mal sagen
was wir auch wissen müssen wir müssen
eigentlich zur bekämpfung der inflation
bei der europäischen zentralbank eine
ansteigende zinsen sorgen diese
steigenden zinsen führen wiederum zu
einer zahlungsunfähigkeit von
griechenland frankreich und italien und
deswegen kann die europäische
zentralbank das momentan nicht anheben
das ist der hintergrund der debatte
deswegen weiß ich nicht ob wir klug
beraten zudem deutschland einzelgänger
zu machen weil wir dann am ende wiederum
indirekt
korrupter staat nach gibt es zu viel
aber schlecht aufgestellte
staatshaushalt den anderen länder der
europäischen union finanziert wir müssen
das eine tun ohne das andere zu lassen
und nach natürlich ist diese ezb
überlagerung für uns ein massives
problem ich glaube sie haben auch völlig
recht wenn sie die politischen motive
der ezb ein stück weit da auch mit
ansprechen natürlich respektieren wir
die geldpolitische unabhängigkeit der
ezb bei zur wahrheit gehört und das
sehen wir ja auch seit vielen jahren
zunehmend das natürlich an mancher
stelle da auch
wirtschaftspolitik mit gemacht wird das
bundesverfassungsgericht lang darauf
hingewiesen und natürlich hängt viel
unserer inflation auch in europa im
moment am handeln der ezb aber ich sage
auch der verweis auf die ezb entbindet
uns nicht von der verpflichtung dass wir
auch am steuerrecht was machen weil wir
diskutieren jetzt über 12 euro
mindestlohn und sie müssen wissen das
finde ich richtig gerade in der
aktuellen inflationsrate dass der lohn
12 euro im durchschnitt beträgt
staatlicher eingriff jetzt mal ein
angestellt aber mit 12 euro mindestlohn
landet jetzt der arbeitnehmer der diesen
mindestlohn besteht schon im
steuerprogression tarif das ist absurd
das können sie keinem erklären gerade
die kleinen und mittleren einkommen sind
die die im moment die last tragen und
der staat verdient durch die erhöhte
mehrwertsteuer-einnahmen und diese
mehreinnahmen die wir im moment haben an
der stelle insgesamt haben wir natürlich
große lasten zu schultern aber der
inflations mehr gewinn aus
mehrwertsteuer und anderen der muss
direkt in die entlastung fließen und das
muss der anspruch sein das macht die
ampel im moment ja aber ich hätte hier
noch eine ergänzung erst einmal freue
ich mich sehr in diesem zusammenhang was
sie gesagt haben montgomery das hat ja
eine domino wirkung hin gesamte eu und
wir wissen wenn wir ins trudeln kommen
mit unserer währung beispielsweise ist
in griechenland das licht sehr schnell
wieder aus den wir garantieren dass ja
alles das muss man einfach sehen und wie
das geleistet werden soll kann er aus
meiner sicht nur sagen wir müssen alle
ausgaben einer aufgabe aufgaben kritiker
unterziehen und müssen die
leistungsträger stärken und das
bildungssystem
wir können heute keine genügend
ausbildungsplätze früher hatten wir mal
ausbildungsplatz not heute haben wir
überschuss wir sind nicht in der lage
aufgrund der niedrigen
bildungsvoraussetzungen die unsere
schulen produzieren die leute
unterzubringen wir haben
fachkräftemangel ich freue mich über
jeden ukraine wer weiß mehr mit zehn
jahren ich habe drei kinder in meinem
haus untergebracht aus der ukraine da
ist ein zehnjähriger schüler dagegen die
vierte klasse der kästner schule in
berlin der erklärte die lehrer den
laptop zehn jahre alt aus der ukraine
kommen das ist der standort deutschland
zu tragen war auf nein das
taxi sitzen oder ich hab sie sind ja
ordentlich ich bin der meinung es muss
eine totale aufgabenkritik universitäten
her wir haben einen bauch angefressen
unnützen dingen die wir mittels
mitschleppen wenn wir das nicht tun und
die masse sagt ab dann kann ich sagen
gute nacht demokratische entwicklung
habe weil da auch klischees zeug an der
rechten seite und auf der anderen seite
sagt bereiten sich auch die hände und
wir ranken im alltag
noch nicht so sehr aber das wird schon
kommen und ich habe patienten die spüren
sehr ich denke dass wir schon auch
irgendwo einen punkt heran kommen wo wir
uns überlegen müssen dass vieles von den
problemen die wir heute haben aus
aufgrund von irrationalität entstanden
ist dass wir als gesellschaft nicht mehr
rational und lösungen streiten sondern
emotionale glaubenssätze als maßstab
setzen jeder der kritisiert ist dann ein
lügner klimaleugner als nazi und so
weiter wir haben bei der energiepolitik
wir haben beim vielen anderen bereichen
auch bei gesundheit ist inzwischen so
ein moralismus drin und das habe ich
finde ich auch dass das ist bei carola
ja auch das dominierende von anfang an
gewesen dass das kostet wahnsinnig viel
geld hätte sieht man jetzt hört man bei
den beiden energiegeschichte was gerade
passiert die kosten von corona ist sind
immens die hat übrigens ein beamter des
bundesinnenministeriums ganz früh
berichtet wurde als belohnung jetzt vom
dienst entfernt und armut macht krank
das wissen wir und und wir müssen zurück
hören zu einer zu einer diskussion die
wirklich rational ist das sagt jemand
der die ganze zeit irrational
haben eine sperrzeit sie haben eine
sprache ich bin bestimmt sie haben eine
sprache die finde ich wirklich
bemerkenswert sie haben ja sie haben
terroristen die leute genannt sie haben
sie doch anschaffungen doch sie haben
gesagt
unsere die internet ende der senken
gekommen und hätte das war heute sehr
gut wenn sie mögen wir auch morgen
wieder zischen abend noch
[Musik]